i thought this debate was settled i
thought that gif with a hard g
had won but apparently not it is more
popular than jif but it's not a
landslide in a 2014 survey only 70
of people said gif and the format's
creator steve wilheit
argues that it should be jiff and has
been arguing that for a long time in
fact when the webby awards let him give
one of their famous
five words only acceptance speeches he
said it's pronounced
jif not gif
this is the slide he put up with that
and uh yeah
you can see the problem there now one of
the most fundamental principles of
modern linguistics is descriptivism
there should be no value judgment about
particular words
or pronunciations or types of speech
there must be no correct way to speak
handed down from on high we describe how
people speak if language changes we
change with it
so the oxford english dictionary accepts
both pronunciations
despite steve wilheit calling them wrong
end of story
turns out even if you invented a word
you don't get to make the call on how
it's pronounced whether he likes it or
not
gif is the more common pronunciation
that said
linguistics also gives us the tools to
look at all the other words in english
and figure out well okay
we've got this new word what other words
is it most like
you might hear the argument that gif is
short for graphics interchange format
graphics not graphics but that's not how
english treats acronyms
in jpeg the p isn't short for
photography in the same way
laser isn't pronounced lassa and scuba
isn't
scuba so rather than acronyms what about
other english words
well in the red corner get gift gaffer
in the blue corner gin gist gel
okay so if you went through the whole
dictionary which side would have more
words well in 2015 a research called
michael dao
did just that only counting the words
that have one morpheme so words like
gift you can't break that down to
smaller lexical parts gifted wouldn't
count you can break that down to
gift and ed so just using those really
basic words
it's a victory for the jiffers there are
more words where gi is pronounced
but the gear words are used more often
so the likelihood of each pronunciation
is
about equal but if you only look at
words that start with gi
ge is more common so now we're on a
question of psycholinguistics when we
read a new word do we consider
all the times we've seen those letters
before anywhere or do we favor ones that
are in the same position and
and even if we do why do we pick one
over the other
unless you're very young gif is a word
that you almost certainly read
before you heard and the first time you
ever saw those three letters your brain
instantly tried to match them to
patterns you already knew jib gift
gin git give maybe jill or gil both of
which are valid english words one's an
old measurement one's a part of a fish
gillingham or gillingham both english
towns a couple hundred miles apart
in a split second your brain went
through everything that it knew
about g i decided which pronunciation
you thought was right and then
locked that in your head the correct
answer is of course
my co-author gretchen mcculloch has a
great podcast called enthusiasm that
covers all sorts of things like this
i recommend it and the link is in the
description
you